c'est très simple il ya regarder les
écrans là et en fait c'est directement
relié à la voilà non je n'essaie de la
love machine c'est vraiment frère il ya
deux capteurs qui sont reliés à
bluetooth et qui sont reliés voilà en
bluetooth à un écran full dit on va
mettre les mains et on va voir notre
compatibilité ça marche d'accord
attention les divines et elle s'est
parée à genève isabelle avec moi je leur
part accusé alors nous et on a ces morts
de chez moi non non rien faire du tout
dans les vieux pots la sensée partie
balesi fausse arme à la main biesheim à
la main
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais être sincère une bonne fois pour
toute et parce que c'est vrai que c'est
un sujet qui traîne depuis des années
cela m'a plu aux téléspectateurs qu'ils
nous rejoignent
c'est que jean luc est quand même le
plus drôle de l'émission non non non je
n'ai eu ses prétentions à magna mais
pour moi je peux vous dire qu'on paye
pas pour le public mais pour vous c'est
vrai que le sniper officielle donc celui
voilà qu'il se rende et ban avec qui
l'on sait que c'est me morice et fils
est donné c'est un humour etc or il
aurait nourri jacob non non et ce n'est
que revienne et vous quand il n'est pas
là vous mettez là pour être un petit peu
le poil à gratter de l'émission oui non
mais il ya des gens plus il met ma photo
à chaque fois que je suis pas là les
gens pensent que je suis décédé quand je
suis pas dans les missions des gens
m'appellent entendre mais tu as un
problème tu es malade et où je vais dire
une bonne fois pour toutes que moi aussi
j'ai beaucoup appris avec toi et je vais
te sincère véritablement pour moi
actuellement
tu es le meilleur sniper de la
télévision et je pense que c'est pour ça
que tout bon dans le christ appelle mst
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est lu et maxime après la santé vous
bien sûr vu les poids me se moquer week
attention c'est parti
ce sont le dos non non non moi c'est pas
du tout absolument pas fiscal encore
mais non la piste
[Applaudissements]
lalonde
l'amour
quel est quel est le plus grand moment
d'émotion que vous ayez augmenter les
bons trucs qui vous a le plus ému
c'était le mariage
bah oui gilles a demandé femme en
mariage que j'en ai dit moi j'avais il
avait les larmes aux yeux quand je serai
descendre et servait l'émotion et lara
sera en deuil on avait tellement peur
pour lui je me rappelle moi j'étais
j'étais pas bien mais je me rappelle je
me suis tu rends compte
à combien j'ai payé mon match et mis sur
la bague bricoler c'est rudy nos frères
d'ailleurs tout le monde demande quand
on va être votre mariage
oui parce qu'on doit faire l'enterrement
de vie de garçon mais bon c'est vrai
merci domenech joue en forêt qu'à régler
en deux minutes
merci attention c'est parti
concentre-toi baisse pas la peine de
faire c'est plus tard non monsieur
martin la main les plus grosses que la
table
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
maxime quand tu pars au campus juste
appel au savoir stephen elop d'agde et
postaux fait là le gars m'a dit c'est
bon t'as des bonnes mains merci ouais je
préfère tes mains c'est beau et on en
est au niveau du bouloir j'ai des
millions de personnes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà